[Music]
Los Angeles is home
I was born and raised here I come from
midwives and I heard their stories as a
child growing up
in Los Angeles County african-american
women are two to three times more likely
to suffer premature birth or to have a
baby die within the first year you have
to ask the question is the hospital
really the safest place for them and my
mission is all around making a change in
these statistics midwifery is closing
the gap because each person is given a
path midwives are not anti hospitals
midwives are not anti doctors we are
advocates for people having access to
the care that they want that means they
have the choice to give birth in a
hospital in a birth center or at home
but supporting them whichever way they
go and then getting the best possible
care right now with you were to Google
midwifery you would find the majority of
people represented are an elite group
more specifically white and so I see
myself as hopefully someone who's an
advocate for those that are completely
disregarded and unseen in our community
and if you ask those women they'll tell
you well it feels really good to be seen
by someone who looks like me
who understands the microaggression who
understands the stress of just being a
person of color in the United States
this is the community birth center and
it's located in mid-city I run the birth
center it was funded by women in the
community who I had served as a midwife
and what they find when they come is a
warm inviting space when they make it
into the exam room it's a conversation
what's going on what can I do for you
today
you're fine when I get
like a small planet attached here great
last year 2014 I had one premature baby
out of 100 babies born outside of the
hospital
and in the hospital one premature baby
that's kind of a big deal are you having
any dizziness or any lightheadedness
most midwives in a day are gonna see six
to ten people maybe on a really busy day
twenty as opposed to having to have the
caseload of a doctor this is where we
see a big difference specifically for
african-american families the community
birth center offers a sliding scale for
families in need the average cost for
out of hospital birth with a midwife in
Los Angeles is $6,500
I charge five thousand I could never
charge someone something that I couldn't
afford
being a single mom there are days that I
don't feel like I have enough fiscally
emotionally spiritually all of them I I
just don't have enough but I figure it
out will lack of income ultimately close
the community birth center it's a very
strong possibility but I'll keep doing
it for as long as I can and I will never
stop giving people care I will never
stop the sliding scale it comes with
great sacrifice but it's worth it
you